space scientists were hit hard earlier
this month when the world's second
largest radio telescope
collapsed look at that the arecibo
observatory in puerto rico was shown in
blockbuster movies like the james bond
hit golden eye
and the science fiction classic contact
well now china is opening the world's
largest radio telescope to international
scientists
cbs news is the only u.s tv network
granted permission to see
the more than 1600 foot telescope
raymien ascencio shows us what he found
nestled shining in silence in the
forested limestone hills of remote
southwest
china the world's biggest single dish
radio telescope
more than five football fields across is
now scanning beyond our skies
its chinese name tinyan means i of
heaven
twelve families were first relocated out
of this natural depression
engineers laid down more than four 000
aluminum panels over a year
to detect faint mysterious fast radio
bursts and ripples in space-time
and to search for signs of
extraterrestrial life
this telescope is some 26 years in the
making
and became fully operational last
january
cbs news gained television access on a
cold december weekend
only because the telescope was offline
for maintenance
we've got the highest sensitivity in the
world says wang chi ming fast's chief
inspector
see that huge steel ring see those six
towers piercing the clouds
they're spectacular and gigantic we're
all
so happy this is the apple of this
cosmic eye
the 30 ton feed cabin hoisted by those
towers nearly
500 feet up its job to collect data from
the universe
reflected from the dish breathtaking to
see it
all physically complete what we don't
see
is also super interesting a mandatory
radio quiet zone that stretches more
than three miles in every direction
right from here scientists want to
listen to very faint radio waves coming
from
millions of light years away not from
someone's cell phone down the road
the fast telescope is now even more
important to the world
after the catastrophic collapse of the
arecibo radio telescope
in puerto rico just weeks ago a 900-ton
feed cabin plummeted through the radio
dish after multiple suspension cables
failed
i asked wong who visited arecibo how he
felt
he said he grieved for the loss of a
partner and good friend for half a
century
and said china would share its telescope
with the world
astronomy has no borders he says this
kind of science
includes us all for cbs this morning
raimi in ascencio in remote guijo
province
southwest china such an important i mean
we need
telescopes like that to be able to
figure out what's going on in outer
space i do believe
i do believe i do too you do i do all
right all right
whoa live long and prosper eureka duncan
i know jamie's like star trek nerds here